intentions en ouvrant ses volets un
matin un homme a la désagréable surprise
de voir que durant la nuit
un campeur installé sa tente sur sa
pelouse
bonjour messieurs c'est moi vous
déranger mais d'où venez vous je viens
du canoë de 17h45 vous savez vous êtes
là et je suis survie de légères et vous
savez à qui il appartient de ses
cocotiers septembre ou la non mais je ne
vais pas tarder à le savoir
ah bon la trésorerie qui l'eût cru jouer
avec moi je m'appelle non mais je ne
vais pas tarder à le savoir
vendredi ah non nous sommes mardi des
jolies qu'il est bête
je suis ici pour deux raisons d'abord
parce qu'on m'a chassé il n'y a pas le
temps en fait un endroit toujours des
risques
la deuxième c'est que j'ai décidé de
vivre en solitaire côté messieurs vous
êtes sur ma pelouse
c'est à vous cette pelouse aujourd'hui
c'est d'avoir cette pelouse dans ses
rosiers c'est à vous oui c'est à moi je
trouve qu'ils sont trop bien monter à
bord c'est tout à faut s'en occuper mais
j'aurais préféré vous y plante y aider
des anémones n'est ce pas d'album forgan
demande comment vont pleinement
complètement d'austérité alors été
monsieur je vous somme de titi s'ils
peuvent apporter à la campagne alors ne
me parlez pas de campagne j'ai loupé la
mienne comme ceci
non vous ne savez pas qui je suis non
pas du tout vous n'avez pas la télé non
si l'on a le devoir et blanc c'est tout
vous avez des trois chênes
je vous n'avez pas les 3 c est comment
je vais faire ça le dit vendredi qu'il
est bête non
samedi pour voir dallas dur dur les
boules monsieur votre tante et sur ma
pelouse
comment vous parlez de temps au tour on
m arriver d'une minute à l'autre
prenez de la situation risque d'être
compromettantes compromettantes
oui non et des mois à monter ma tante du
tout ici là tout de suite
bah oui tout de suite les prétentions de
dormir sur l'herbe d'autant que
rodrigues et plein de fourmis rouges
avons une habitante
aidez moi à planter ma tente c'est moi
de mon slam tenait les filles bougez pas
je vais d'ailleurs j'ai entendu marchiez
vous avez entendu marché mais non ce
n'est qu'une loi de coco